he is a baseball hall-of-famer
first-ballot guy John Smoltz back here
in the Rich Eisen show how are you John
good afternoon doing good oh my gosh
what in the hell happened in the seventh
inning last night John Smoltz that was
totally insane yeah it was you know
thankfully for the Nationals the two-run
homer
takes the sting out of that you know
they came off a game where they were a
little bit upset with the game before
and some things that didn't go their way
and strike zone and you know what could
have been should have been stuff but you
know what at the end of the day the
Washington Nationals have some kind of
resilience that I haven't seen in a long
time to have for elimination games
played in the postseason I can't
remember another team that's been able
to do something like that and I got to
give him a lot of credit man they're the
emotions of the game you get lost in it
sometimes they were able to with the
most quietest heartbeat guy it was
probably the right guy to come up after
all that commotion went down and he hits
that two-run homer and you wouldn't know
if he won the lottery or he just lost
three dogs you know because he's
definitely a guy who can play to one
beat of the drum so it's the eye of the
beholder
I get it it's the most controversial
rule we have and some debate I'm sure in
the offseason on what to do and how this
play could be altered and and viewed
differently it's it's not quite like the
past interference play in NFL but it's
pretty close well it's interesting that
you bring up the NFL John because to me
you know I started the show by saying
that I agreed with the call that I
thought that Turner you know did run the
base pads just like me virtually every
major league baseball runner trying to
beat it on down the line does but he did
there was contact made with the first
baseman whether the throw did or not and
and the the issue that I have is the
Major League Baseball does not require
its umpires to do what NFL refs are
required to do which is to get on a
microphone and explain to everybody what
they've seen and what the ruling is and
then move on III if they could only do
that I think that Mike well a lot of the
confusion and angst and anxiety of the
whole situation yeah there's no doubt
that's been another topic for a lot of
people you know wanting that to take
place and you know there are some moving
parts with that it is a little bit
different but III believe that
eventually something like that needs to
be explained maybe by somebody up in the
booth that's a former umpire that can in
at least give the verbage to the to the
announcer that can give the fans
something to write to know what's going
on in and again you know this said
bangbang sport the guy behind home plate
dealing with 99 98 miles an hour and
break balls strike zones been a little
bit if he if to say the least this this
world series
bang-bang plays at first we saw it it's
a hard it's a hard sport and I think
though at this level you know with this
much at on the line I just think I just
think there's got to be some
reconsideration for certain things to be
looked at that are currently not being
looked at under the rules of replay and
I don't think anyone would have a
problem with that if they expand it
whether it's the did the ball hit the
bat on a you know foul ball swing and a
Miss strike three right or the judgment
calls I get it I understand why you just
open up a huge box of judgment calls
them to come you know more more ability
to look at those things and and and I
don't I don't have the answer that but I
think there will be some discussion and
I'd like I said we're talking about it
but it's not to the degree that it could
have been if that game stayed a one-run
game and somehow someway Washington
wasn't able to win it they were winning
when that play and that call was made
they weren't losing but then all of a
sudden you start feeling the carryover
of the game before and he's just you
could understand why they were Aang
John Smoltz baseball hall-of-famer and
calling the game with Joe Buck you guys
are such a great listen and great watch
I've really enjoyed it and just one last
on this subject before we turn the page
to tonight again having it the the
umpires put the headsets on when you're
saying it on the broadcast this is not
reviewable right and then just only adds
to the confusion then the UMP just gives
an outside and we're supposed to
interpret what the hell all that stuff
means and and and you know that sort of
material needs to be worked out it all
does start with the contact at the base
do you think do you think the ball was
purposefully thrown at the runner you
did say during the broadcast last night
this is what you as a pitcher are taught
to do do you think that actually
happened it was just a bang bang mere
happenstance that the ball wound out
where it did yeah it was bang bang the
plays down the line closer to the first
base line whether it's the catcher
throwing or kids are coming over the
field that those are the ones you got to
try to throw and get it in the line in
case you get the call I mean that's what
we were taught you throw it right at the
back of the runner and some out like I
did last night for the Astros in a way
where either Gary L could have got his
glove out in front and gone got the ball
a little bit easier but all that led to
making it look like it was worse than it
was and that's the biggest toughest
scenario to to you know kind of quantify
and I think look I've heard all kinds of
suggestions I've heard get the softball
base get the base fare at foul territory
for the runner so that the runner has a
better Lane because when you're when
you're running for a base hit
you would never run like that because
you would run to round the bag right if
you're going for a double you would
never run like that because you're
running to go for a double but when
you're trying to beat out an infield hit
that's where you're running and so
that's the difference on those plays
when you would be outside the line and
you would be making your turn but the
fastest way to a base and when it's a
bang-bang play straight so that that
would help
the base was more in foul territory it
would give the baserunner a bag a part
of the bag to go to and it would give
the infielder the ability to have the
bag so maybe that's I've heard that
being said and thrown around maybe
that's that helps few more minutes it'll
have left with you John Smoltz let's
turn to tonight what type of Scherzer do
you think we're gonna get John you know
it's really interesting because every
pitcher has been through similar things
that he has adrenaline will get him
through the early part of the game he's
physically loose and able to do what he
wants to do that I think he'll be fine
he'll be amped up but I think there will
be some residual soreness no doubt we've
all pitched with discomfort and you just
you know at least he's getting an
opportunity to pitch I mean you just
felt terrible for him when he couldn't
go the day that he was asked to go and
woke up I just you know you just hate
that
and now at least the Nationals got their
wish they wanted they wanted Scherzer
and Strasburg the pitch again if they
were gonna get this series to a game
seven and they're gonna have Scherzer
pitched game seven with a little bit
more backup now if you think about it
they're gonna have Corbin Sanchez
they're gonna have the best formula for
them to win aside from them being up two
games to none when they went home with
the best formula to win so again we've
never seen anything like this I've never
seen a series where every home game has
been lost and I've never seen anything
quite like this series on the swings of
emotion and the swings of a series that
have kind of gone and in and I mean it's
basically a series of the unexpected it
just when you think you're gonna expect
something just the opposite happens and
that's what the series turned into well
and you have been on unfortunately the
wrong end of an unexpected Game seven
situation when you started in 91 you
went up against a bulldog pitcher which
I think you can describe Scherzer as and
Jack Morris who went 10 and it was a one
nothing final and one of the greatest
World Series game sevens we've ever seen
what is it
to pitch in a pressure situation like
that and get matched zero for zeros like
that John what is that like well it it
should be the game you've dreamed up
your whole life and I did I mean I make
no bones about it I wanted to be in
every type of seventh game there was I
think it's the greatest boom in the
world I think the hardest game in the
world is when you're not playing in a
game seven because you have no control
of your stomachs and knots and you're at
the mercy of whatever your teammates are
doing and the crowds gonna be super loud
here's the way I've always broken it
down you're gonna have a loud crowd one
way or another if you're the home team
you've got to deal with it you can't let
it get you to Inc and amped up if you're
the visiting team you got to deal with
it and better get it to a dull roar but
it's going to be loud and if that's the
one area that you can control the
dullness of the Roar or the loudness of
the Roar are going to indicate and
determine how you're doing because if
you don't take the crowd out of it
they're going to be loud you're going to
be fighting the feeling of trying to
pitch perfect and there's no way that
you can pitch a game trying to pitch
perfect and that's the one thing that
guys have to fight against because when
you get a runner on first for whatever
reason in the postseason you start
feeling like that's a huge rally you
can't let that happen
you're a pitch away from a double play
kids you just can't get caught up in
that everything the magnification of
this this game it makes you false read
what's going on and the person that can
handle it and slow the heartbeat down is
going to be the persons or the team that
come out on top I kind of think in a
weird way Zack Greinke and all that he
is and what he kind of goes through and
his personality might actually be a
pretty good guy to have because he's not
really thinking too much about anything
in his own way he's unique and you know
the game like this might not be that big
of a deal to him well man enjoy it soak
it in like I said you and Joe are just
such a great listen and
and it's it's all good when you guys are
calling the game
I can't wait to settle into not tonight
thanks for the call John hit him
straight tonight yes all right take care
that's John Smoltz for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app